[Music]
airbnb will go public with an estimated
market valuation of over 42 billion
dollars
a remarkable feat when considering just
eight months ago
the home sharing giant was in crisis
mode with its business being crushed by
the coronavirus pandemic
from april to june 2020 revenue was down
72 percent
as travel and bookings came to a virtual
standstill worldwide
here's how airbnb managed to pivot
towards profitability during a global
pandemic
and how it might fare amongst continued
travel restrictions
and beyond when the pandemic struck in
march
travel restrictions around the world
sent airbnb's bookings and revenues
into freefall bookings in europe alone
went down 80
airbnb was burning through its reserves
and needed a swift infusion of cash
so its first lifeline was securing 2
billion
in loans but these didn't come cheap
so when the pandemic hit airbnb was
bleeding through its cash reserves and
it needed a swift infusion of cash
but the loan that they got was came at a
very steep
interest rate and it was an interest
rate of 11 which is
often associated with distressed assets
at this point airbnb's valuation had
fallen from 31 billion dollars in 2017
to 18 billion in april 2020. despite
this
airbnb was still under pressure to go
public by year's end
so airbnb's ceo had toyed with the idea
of going public for years but he'd
stopped short of pulling the trigger now
that was leading to some anxieties
setting
in among early investors and a handful
of employees
who were set to lose their stock options
next year
like many other companies during the
pandemic airbnb
dramatically reduced its cost to get by
costs that have grown significantly over
the last few years
before the pandemic airbnb had expanded
into new areas like transportation and
media
and spent big on things like marketing
and a new corporate headquarters
increasing the company's total cost more
than fivefold between 2015
and 2019. so even before the pandemic
you had board members
asking executives hey why are your costs
so high
airbnb spent big to expand into all
sorts of new areas it also spent
big on a new corporate headquarters and
it
typically spends um heavily on things
like sales and marketing
to alleviate its balance sheets airbnb
cut big expenses
put many non-corporate projects on hold
and laid off a quarter of its staff
they early on said that their founders
wouldn't take a salary
they cut pay in half for top executives
they slashed sales and marketing
expenses
but it still wasn't enough we spoke to
ceo brian chesky
and he said he went through
his accounts line by line to see what
could be cut
but none of airbnb's maneuvers would
work if people didn't start booking on
its platform again
so the third move it made was to adapt
its platform for pandemic travel
people were sitting at home they still
wanted to travel but they
couldn't get onto flight so what people
start doing is that they start driving
to smaller towns and cities
and what do they do they book airbnbs
because big hotel chains don't have a
footprint there
so airbnb gets lucky before the pandemic
big cities visited by taurus had been
airbnb's strength
but these new local stays in primarily
suburban in rural locations became the
company's focus
ceo brian chesky sees this trend and
immediately capitalizes on it the
company redesigned its website and its
app
so its algorithm would show prospective
travelers everything from cabins to
lavish beach houses near where they
lived
by august more than half of bookings
were made for stays within 300
miles of guest's location according to
the company
and these moves helped stem the losses
and reservations
the company reported a surprise profit
in the third quarter
this quarter is typically the most
lucrative for the company and airbnb has
turned a profit in that period every
year since 2017.
airbnb has never had a full year profit
but its turnaround during a global
pandemic
and at a time when the hotel industry is
drowning has buoyed investors confidence
and helped its valuation bounce back
one of airbnb's near-term challenges is
of course the pandemic
what will that look like in the future
how does travel change
as a result of that separately the
company has
traditionally struggled to police
crime on its platform and that is
expected to get
a lot more scrutiny as the company
sells its shares to the public skeptics
wonder how long the company can keep
costs down and stick to its core
business
and questions remain on whether the
growth in revenue in bookings is
sustainable
or whether airbnb is simply the main
beneficiary of a battered hospitality
industry